hey guys dr. Burke here in this video I
want to show you what to do for flat
feet now I have severe flat feet ever
since I was a kid and I did all sorts of
arch supports and it never really worked
because I'm here I'm standing on my flat
foot you know an arch that's made from
my flat foot it never really fixed it so
I'm going to show you some stretches in
an acupressure points that you can do at
least not to necessarily correct the
flat feet but to give you a lot of
relief this is the only thing that I
found that works so basically we have a
situation where you don't have an arch
it's flat right so everyone's like
massaging the bottom of the foot and
doing all sorts of therapy and it might
give you some relief but you don't want
to do that because we always want to
work on the opposite side of where the
problem is why because this is going to
relax this muscle by stimulating the top
part now the first thing we'll do is to
show you a stretch so we're going to
take the toes and by the way this is the
same thing you do for plantar fasciitis
- which is pain in the bottom of the
foot so you take the toes and we're
going to stretch them like this we're
going to stretch and stretch about 10
times and we're actually stretching this
whole muscle right through and here what
that will do that will give the foot the
signals are sent to relax the bottom of
the foot it will really give you a lot
of relief okay so we're going to stretch
that okay the other thing you can do is
you can sit on your feet like this and
you can see right here that I'm
automatically just the weight of my body
is stretching the front part of my foot
the muscles on the front part of the
foot which is the called the anterior
tibialis and so we're stretching this
and we're rocking back and forth and of
course if you need to use like some type
of cushion like if you can't do this
position to sit on it that's fine but
you want to gradually stretch this part
right here okay step two is to work on
the front of the foot the muscles and
the tissues in the front of foot you
just stimulate
the top of the foot like this especially
like right into here and what you're
going to find on people with flat feet
it's going to be extremely tender so you
just want to work out the top of the
foot no one does this they're working on
the bottom of the foot this is a faster
way to give your feet a lot of relief so
I'm just working on all the different
muscles on the top part for maybe a
minute you do the other side of course
okay and then what happens when you're
done you're going to feel the bottom of
your feet feels so so good it's going to
feel really good now step two if you
have cramping in your feet or your cap
that always means that you need a little
bit of calcium so take calcium magnesium
before bed don't take it with us with
food have at an empty stomach right
before bed if there's actual cramping in
the foot you know sometimes when you
point your toe and you get that cramp
that's a different situation okay
so go ahead and apply these techniques
put your comments below and subscribe to
my channel and I'll see you in the next
video